hey what's going on man how are you how
are you were on the air
yeah hey what's up what's up buddies we
didn't know that you were coming in
because our Booker never told us so they
left a book for us and we didn't get it
until right before the show so
congratulations good thank you man I
literally open one page and I laughed it
was the Steve Harvey a story about the
first time we do the Apollo yeah the
first time I did the Apollo and he liked
you yeah and he offered to take you he
wanted to give you some sage advice What
did he say I remember it's been so long
but he wanted to give you a limo ride
and you just didn't get into little yeah
yeah why is that just because I don't
know what I said I'm gonna be honest
with you know I know this is ready over
I think I had the booboo and I I had to
go see Harvey I gotta see it I wanted to
tell you could you wait but I just said
I couldn't do it and I had to go use the
restaurant man right that really is the
best excuse mentorship for not getting a
Steve Harvey's win oh that's the honest
truth and when I got done he was gone
he's not waiting for you to [ __ ] no it's
like I liked you I didn't like you that
much so I had it itchy ass and
opportunity right off this book yes my
first book I was reading some of it and
I liked the attack that you take with
your early life and and the crimes that
you might or might not have been
involved with it's very odd Jay
hypothetical right like it's like I know
this is this maybe I don't know what the
statute of limitations is so maybe it
happens is climber
smart smart way to handle it you had you
I guess you started out and uh you could
have went down a bad path is that what
happened you kind of start with you
would you grow up I grew up in Indiana I
grew up in Indianapolis Indiana okay and
that's where Marion County is yeah and
you went to jail there yeah Marion
County Jail yeah I did two years in the
county jail
I've always wondered like when you would
a guy comes from selling drugs where
there's quick money and easy money and
all this stuff and then it's like okay
maybe I can try comedy and comedy is a
place where everyone's like man you got
to pay your dues you got it's slow and
steady wins the race and stuff but you
just came from this world where there's
quick
money yeah right there how do you
justify that like how do you not just be
like [ __ ] paying your dues I'm just
gonna go back to selling drugs and
making money well you know what what I
found out about being a drug dealer and
being a street guy is that everybody
wants Fame and I said if I'm on the
track of being famous why should I sell
drugs right you know what I mean like
that's really a drug dealers ultimate
goal is to be famous this I mean after
they get the money is I mean if you
watch American Gangster right that's
what got Lucas in trouble is that he
went to the the fight with this big-ass
fur coat and they noticed nobody but him
right so right and before that didn't
even know who he was so didn't know who
he was right Fame sometimes get us in
trouble well that's also to being
pussy-whipped to because Frank Lucas his
wife gave him that jacket he knew not to
be flashy but he [ __ ] put it on
anyway because I gonna tell her no yeah
use that god damn it I should've just
dealt with that I guess people do want
to be famous and doing - did you two
years for it was for drugs
yeah two years sounds wrong it and and
Pryor who I want to talk to you about -
did a very funny a bit years ago about
if you don't want to get raped in jail
keep people laughing how did it work for
you when you were in jail well I ain't
no bump you know what I mean and uh so I
really didn't have them kind of problems
you know what I mean and most of the
guys in there was people I knew people I
went to school with you know summer camp
because all the kids what thing about
the streets and one thing about your
being in the streets is that when you
become older and you are and you go to
jail and you're walking around in jail
and you see all these other inmates and
you know you know I'm from nice humbling
childhood [ __ ] right like do what you in
here for he's like oh I'm in here for
homicide I'm like wow I remember we went
to camp together
you know it means that you know that guy
you don't know this other guy like this
is our guy
he just grew up and happen you know yeah
but does that make it easier though he's
like you know him from a nicer time and
he knows you from a nicer time so you
you might you don't have to deal with
him the way people who meet him later in
life do that's right because because
because if somebody knows you as a child
is it's like a shoo-in to safety yeah
you know what I mean like I can't hurt
you you know it even even some of the
most craziest guys out on the street are
killers you know if if if a killer was
about to shoot somebody and you had the
knowledge of who he was and said hey is
your grandmother named Rose he'll
probably put that gun down and say some
[ __ ] just sticks you yeah there's
something about knowing somebody from
childhood is a weird connection and it's
also like they know me that's right we
all are who we want to be as adults but
like around people like family whatever
like oh no like shut off right like you
have to not you have to shut that part
of your brain off so when you start
saying like oh yeah from when we were
kids it's like oh wait we're real people
now like we can't do this yeah so when
you start when you're in prison and you
start looking around and you're like
these are all a lot of these people I
know from growing up like and you start
looking around like wait this is the
path that we're all on is that the time
when you start going like I got to
change something well you know when you
locked up you know you wake up different
everyday you know you wake up some days
you wake up and you say man I have no
business in here and then some days you
wake up and like man I'm about to go out
there and play some poker and and play
some cards and or shoot some dice and
try to win some extra popcorn today you
know because that's the money in there
is food because they don't have real
money right so you know you you you come
out your cell and you see this round
table full of guys playing cards and
down by their legs is all their
commissary and that's it again tortilla
chips popcorn all this [ __ ] is down this
they just any time they lose they just
take his snacks and slide them over this
is my who's already thought for you that
this is the way things are just gonna be
forever like when you when you first go
in it's got to be horrible you get two
years or you like [ __ ] this is never
gonna change
well unfortunately I caught three cases
back-to-back in within five years felony
cases and they were about to file what
they call there's a three-strike law but
in Indiana they call it the habitual
criminal they were gonna file the mini
[ __ ] on me [ __ ] war criminal carries I
automatic 30 years for continuing to get
in trouble the mini [ __ ] was half of
that which was 15 years so I slipped out
the cracks man you know yeah how come
they didn't charge you with that uh
I said that I was in drug addict that I
that I was addicted to drugs that sure
no no fabrication oh yeah that was smart
thing to say yeah but what helped me was
is that I did get violated because I had
cocaine in my system and I didn't I
didn't get cocaine in my system from
doing cocaine but I got cocaine in my
system from bagging it up in the
summertime and my hands sweating Wow
so it kind of seeps into your it goes in
your pores wow so that's how they got a
lot of guys - a lot of guys did that got
25 years or to life or whatever because
they had two things on him and they got
busted for pot and that became the third
there's a bunch of people in jail for
pot because they had two other felonies
it's ridiculous yeah yeah that's how
they do it I mean if the if the system
drug tested drug dealers who claimed
they didn't do drugs if they was
anywhere around that they would find
cocaine they system right now I mean
we're backing it up when you get busted
three times in five years back to back
to back to back do you realize like I'm
just not that guy that gets away with
[ __ ] I'm gonna just keep getting busted
I looked at it that way and I looked at
it
God was sending me a sign saying this is
not for you knock it off knock it off
yeah the book is called unsuccessful
thug which is a great title it's out now
it's the real Mike Epps on on Twitter
and you're doing assigning za-- tomorrow
night at bookends in Ridgewood which is
a great independent bookstore in New
Jersey and also an April 3rd Barnes &
Noble at the Grove in Los Angeles and
now you did a signing last night how
does it feel to have a book like when
you get a whole box of them doesn't it
feel like it's like what an
accomplishment
it goes back to selling drugs daisies I
see all this product sitting in front of
me and I really want to stand on the
corner and just pitch him like this like
they sacks you know remove these books
yeah I got to move these bars is pulling
up to the car with two books and sliding
the money the police comes is that how
you do it is that like that's every TV
show I never sold drugs that happens you
hide it somewhere guy gives you the
money and then you send him to somebody
else who actually has it or is it one
guy just doing all of it I mean it
depends on what level of it is you you
own I've always been on the level of
doing it myself you know I never got to
the level where I could tell people you
know because that's the favorite thing
in the hoos I don't touch nothing you
know but I never got to I don't touch
nothing I touched everything did you
keep it on you or did you keep it in a
shrub I've had it on me I've had it in
my drawers I've actually I've actually
been on a set that was so hot that I had
it under my tongue in my mouth so you
know and and we would swallow it and if
you ran into a cop that really wanted
your ass he would take you to the
hospital and make you [ __ ] there was a
guy in London yeah there's a story about
a guy in London who set the record
because they knew he had something on I
mean it swallowed it he didn't [ __ ] for
47 days day 47 days that just happened I
don't know if he's finally [ __ ]
but he hadn't tripped on 47 days in the
hospital cause he was sick because he
hadn't [ __ ] for 47 days he set the
record because he's like you're not
getting it a really good I don't know I
don't know he said he refused to ship 47
days I'm agent Lee I'm sure
by the time they got it it was brown
sure that's kind of a that's what when's
the first time you went on stage I went
on stage in 1991 okay so in Indiana how
long had you been out of jail by that
point about six months oh you just came
out and did you kind of know that's what
I'm gonna do well I was always funny I
was always cracking jokes
wherever I was I was cracking jokes and
def Comedy Jam was on and people used to
say man you need to get on that and I
was like yeah I do
I want to do the Comedy Competition one
of my guys I was locked up with rest in
peace his name was oldest Brown he did
20 years in prison and he betted me he
said man you funny at this mountain
barbershop and around everybody but I
bet your ass won't go up in front of
everybody they got a comedy competition
it's Club seville's so I said bet so the
Thursday came around we went to the
comedy competition and he was sitting in
the audience him and another guy named
Gary Bates both of them are deceased now
but they were my friends they were
sitting in the audience and it was a bar
and grill they had pulled off 13 people
everybody in the bar was drunk
they was not there to hear comedy they
was talking everybody to go on stage you
say your first joke the next thing you
hear is get the [ __ ] out of here so I
signed up I was the last one to go up
while I was waiting I was getting drunk
as [ __ ] I wanted to kill my inner
inhibition and I got drunk and went up
on the stage made everybody laugh went
home I was so excited couldn't sleep the
next week came I invited my whole
neighborhood that I invited family
members all kind of people it was a
couple drug dealers that I owed some
money to the showed up to when they
heard my name on the radio contested my
cabs won last week come back and same
again this week is the new winner of the
comedy competition you know
video [ __ ] so I went back I want to
bought a brand new soup I didn't get
drunk went on the stage and got booed
with your family first bomb that was my
first bomb you know love that the drug
dealers were there to collect but they
probably at that point I made my family
wait seven years before they came to see
me up yeah because the movie fame I've
talked about this before from 1980 where
Ralph Garci is the comic and he does
great but then he he goes back with his
friend with his friends he does great
and then he goes back alone he bombs I'm
like I want nobody I know so me for
seven years yeah and you were still
bombing then right seven years in I was
horribly I started now [ __ ] 28 years
and I'm still [ __ ] tanking but yeah
the first bomb that's the hardest one is
the firm work together for years
oh yeah in the city me and him worked in
the cities for years of me and him used
to see each other in passing walking
going to another comedy club and like
hey what's the cellar like it's like oh
it's packed where you going I'm going to
the Boston oh yeah where are you going
you know yeah but I don't know that
world down there in in in in Soho with
the comics I used to see Dave Attell
walking down the street smoking a
cigarette I stopped him were you going
to the cellar yeah where are you going
you know it was it was a world it would
be so great you'd leave the cellar and
walk around the corner on West 3rd to
the Boston comedy club and you know and
Patrice and a lot of guys would just be
sitting out like leaning in front of a
car taught it was do it's too great
place well it was a beautiful world but
it's fun it was fun I do man
I've never thought about going back and
just doing yeah I still go to the cellar
every now and then you did a line one
time you made me laugh so hard and I
can't do it justice because it was a
visual but about an old guy with a crook
in his neck looking back over the left
side of it and I'm like what a perfect I
didn't know the guy he was talking about
but I'm like a hundred percent know this
guy yeah so it's not surprising to me
that they want you to play Pryor if that
rumor is true yeah they wanted me to
play with your prior you know but
the prior project was caught up in the
weinstein company so his wife is trying
to get it out of there to do the movie
so okay and then there's the thing they
were just gonna be sold but so that
there's so much of a mess happening with
that yeah so we got to see what happens
you know is he somebody that you're
comfortable playing or scared to play
I'm comfortable you are I mean we both
from the Midwest we I was born I was
born like a hour and something from
where he lives
llúria we just know we just I just know
that that that Lango you know and I know
that guy
right now is did you when you realize
this was an opportunity did you start to
do your history and brush up on him or
is this somebody that you've been
following oh no I've been following them
for a while I the first time I heard
Richard Pryor was you know I was in a
work release center I just got out and
they sent me to a work release soon any
want to send me straight to the street
and a guy was is I've never forget this
dude's name his name was Earl outlaw he
had sickle cell and he worked for Lay's
potato chips and he was up on the top
bunk laughing hard and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he laughing at and he he said
have you heard this and I put the
headphones on it was Richard Pryor
talking about walking in the woods and
he was looking at this deer and I was
like damn that dude is funny so I've
never paid no more attention to him like
that and then when I started getting
into comedy I'm like you know what I
gotta go to the Wizard
yeah see what the wizard did oh you mean
calling him the wizard or the calling
him okay the album there's a collection
called the wizard it was all his clean
stuff yeah from laughs wreck it was
really weird to hear all their late they
bootleg to [ __ ] a prior album they
just put all these clean bits on it and
when I was a kid listen I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this like I didn't we were
clean no yeah so you were too adult when
you first heard him that's it that's
rare usually most guys I know you hear
them when you were uh I'm guessing were
in the same age I'm 40 and I were close
yeah well if I got that same story is
that my I was sneaking listen I didn't
sneak and do [ __ ] I
you know I did what the hell I wanted at
13 so who'd you listen to it again I
gotta say Eddie Murphy was our comic
yeah Richard Pryor was somebody that I
really really studied and watched after
I found Eddie found out Eddie Murphy
studied Richard Pryor hell why am i
studying anymore I was 30 Richard Pryor
so Eddie Murphy took it to the next
level for our generation when he did
buckwheat has just been shot oh man I
couldn't sleep we were literally waiting
up to watch Saturday Night Live to see
if book we really got shot my brother
got mad and said that is not really buck
mind-blowing then if you get the
opportunity to make this primary because
Eddie Murphy's attached to it too right
well that all of that is old news you
know all of that is old news we don't
know what where the project is going at
this point but uh how do you do you are
you the type that like watches this
thing so you make sure that you hold on
to that prior role just in case it
happens or do you just go whatever
happens happens
it's out there no you know I I said with
Richard Pryor for a year before he
passed away and I studied enough that if
they call me on the set today I could do
it you know yeah wait you sat with him
you went to his house and yeah when he
was he was sick at that point yeah he
was sick and what would you do would you
just sit with him would you talk to him
or I'll be obviously well you know he
had multiple sclerosis so he couldn't
really really talk or move anything it
was a really high conversation I could
look in his eyes and tell when he wanted
to be bothered when he didn't you know I
I just to try to make him laugh but that
[ __ ] didn't work and it didn't work no
and sometimes the look in his eyes was
like if you don't get the [ __ ] out of my
house some days he was his eyes was like
I'm excited to see you know so what are
you doing you were his did his did his
wife I guess Jennifer I'm guessing is
who he was married to at the time but
she said hey come come by and keep him
company he likes you or
how'd that happen yeah yeah yeah he told
me come by and keep him company she said
we'll come by keep him company
you know come and talk to him and I used
to make him try to make him laugh and he
wouldn't laugh and one day the maid
walked past and pulled it and I said am
her booty sound like it'd been tampered
with and he just fell out [ __ ] I see
yeah with moody over there at that time
er no no no no not Moony wasn't around
he wasn't is he sick yeah I've heard he
was second I hope that's not true
yeah I hope he's doing okay yeah so okay
when you got it when you get into comedy
do you leave the drug world behind or
you like I don't really know what this
comedy thing is gonna work out let me
not forego my business that I've already
started just for this like were you
doing both at the same time for a period
no once I stopped one I left it alone
you know like I said I was excited that
I had a talent I didn't give a damn
about no drugs right it was like [ __ ]
drug money so I have so much drug money
when I get done with this so you were
confident from the beginning well I mean
it was just something something in me
that just was like man this is your [ __ ]
you know did you have a moment I wasn't
even thinking about being famous it was
just like damn man I found something I
can really make people laugh Universal
it's just about being good at something
right right did you have a moment the
second time you get up and you bomb when
you go oh [ __ ] maybe I'm not good at
this
no I I didn't bomb like that you know
I'm I think I've been I bomb maybe two
times in my life like wow like real bomb
like a real bomb other than that you
know I'm one of them guys that'll make a
joke out of the bombing yeah [ __ ] I
ain't gonna let you not laugh at me now
right what if I tell a joke and it ain't
funny we laugh and it that [ __ ] together
or if they decide to finally not come
along then I'm just gonna kind of ruin
their night that's happened a lot to
where I can't get
and uh I did one I was I was warming it
for Tonight Show set up this by 2010 and
I'm not the seller but there's a place
down the street and I just needed a spot
and I went in and I bombed so horribly
like it was absolute silence and I
couldn't get them and I realized like
this is what scares people about doing
this that's right
I couldn't get in this what I was
probably in a 2010 I was in 20 years at
that point
and I could not nothing you know you
learn how to get an audience after a
while this works that work this trick
works
nothing works you know like this it was
always helpless on stage so in that
moment are you like in this state of
dread are you like this is it we're in
here right now
I'm just like this is I'm dying and they
didn't even they weren't even heckling
they were just completely bored by me
completely disinterested
it's a chalk up you know I mean I say
this is a straight chalk up you know you
got a chalk that [ __ ] up oh yeah leave
and be like yeah okay that one took a
few days to walk off they did yeah that
was a lot more to question your career
yeah make you say damn a month am I
losing it you know well you're a
comfortable performer like I watch you
you seem like you just enjoy it I
watched the I will forget what special
was was very funny but you walked out
with Dougie fresh I'm like what a fun
way I walk onstage like I would never be
comfortable enough to just go out on
stage and just have that much fun before
I told any jokes you just really you
didn't give a [ __ ]
no okay I don't know who's in the
audience I don't look and I just be
going for with me you know how often do
you do stand-up now I never quit I never
stopped doing stand-up I've been on tour
my whole career you don't like to take
breaks I try not to for too long so I'm
just terrified that everything's going
to go away yeah like if I if I break the
the things I've done they're gonna
completely forget my happy number gonna
change yeah it's very scary but you have
a good movie career to I mean you know
you got a lot of you know you're in a
classic comedy one of the classic
comedies for sure and how did you get
Fridays uh dissing for you oh just a
regular addition I auditioned for but
it was right after the first Friday was
big and I came in and auditioned for it
beat out a lot of comics man but that's
even I mean that's even a scarier thing
to be on next Friday when it's like okay
the first Friday nobody really knew how
big that movie was gonna be but you knew
it was iconic by you know a couple weeks
in you're like okay this movie's gonna
be around forever so to pop in and be
the guy that pops in for the sequel it's
gonna be terrifying it is it's
terrifying and you know it's terrifying
for somebody who you know looks at it a
certain way before me mm-hmm it wasn't
that terrifying because I didn't have
[ __ ] and I didn't have nothing to lose
and I already knew in my head you know
what if this movie don't work
I can go back to to New York and run
around with Jim Norton what a horrible
idea though but if this movie doesn't
work this is what you're stuck with you
talked about in the book a little bit
about leaving New York and going to LA
and how much more comfortable you felt
in LA and you did in New York which I
don't really I guess I don't really hear
that too often I feel more often you
hear people in LA being like oh yeah I
wish I could live in New York but the
business is out here blah blah what was
it about being in New York at that time
that you didn't like it wasn't that I
didn't like New York I Love New York but
I always looked at New York as a
training ground for me I never looked at
it as this is where I'm gonna live you
know I see because I didn't have any
family here and the East Coast is really
really fast mm-hmm and I came from a
pretty laid-back place so when I got to
LA I was like you know what I can really
really do this because I could stretch
out because the weather was good this
was this New York I Love New York this
it was a it was a training ground for me
it was boot camp right and I wouldn't
replace it for nothing in the world
actually when I talked to new comics and
he like oh what should i do i said mood
of New York and you ought to see the
fear and they [ __ ] face when I say
that because this is the real deal well
it seems uncomfortable too there's
there's so many comedians and
so many good comics and again like you
said you got a tell and you all these
funny guys working I'll never conquer
this this will never be a place where
I'm comfortable or liked but it's gonna
be scary I mean when you think about it
like a training ground it's gotta be one
of those spots where if you learn how to
work at that pace wherever you go after
that you're gonna be able to do well
right you know that's right because when
I got there like I was like hey this is
it yeah they not [ __ ] they not hungry
they not that funny you know was like
the comedy clubs was just like I'm like
damn dude so I was by the time I got to
LA I was like man I was fierce well you
know they don't tease each other out
there either like you know there's very
few very few things that felt worse than
when you were going to like say from the
cellar to Boston and you'd be
approaching the club and from half a
block away Patrice and Keith and a bunch
of guys were in the front and they're
looking towards you and they're all
laughing so you know they've begun
attacking you already and you're like
I'm walking right into a [ __ ] beating
and there's enough there's no way to
fight it off you just you're about to
get humiliated you're just trying to get
in the building and they're like look at
this worm something about your pants or
the way you're walking you look dumpy
there's something that they picked up on
and a half a block they have to start on
you but those things I would miss when I
would go to Catholic comedians that you
don't don't interact like this is much
yeah everybody wants a television know
where to [ __ ] perform out there like
that you know they only got like a
couple places like you talked about
going on stage every night you're not
going on stage every night in LA no you
know you get you a good Sunday night
maybe a Monday night spot maybe a spot
on Friday at the Laugh Factory but so
one up every night forget it two spots a
night I think I've done to you spot some
once in LA yeah so you're doing like two
or three spots a week instead of two or
three spots a night right that's crazy
it's also like historically in LA don't
you have a lot more people there trying
to do comedy to get like you just had a
TV show or a movie or something like
that whereas in New York the goal it
really is just to be funnier Yeah right
just to get better at this yeah well to
go in the goal
New York is to do enough paid $25 gig so
you can pay your [ __ ] rent how long
did it take you to pay your rent -
instead of it didn't take long I end up
getting on a def Comedy Jam tour oh you
did so once I got on the def Comedy Jam
tour I was making about seven hundred
two thousand dollars a week I was like
[ __ ] I mean now who hosted when you did
def def jam
I think George Wallace hosted my episode
at that time Martin Lawrence was gone
and it it was they were doing like guest
hosts yeah you know what's funny and I
don't know the guy I've never seen him a
Joe Torre I always liked him as a comic
from the Yankees not that Joe Torre no
another one better built his brother guy
was in American history I know but is he
still he does stand up I guess yeah he's
still out there Joe story's still out
there so how long was it from the time
the one year dude said to you you have
to be on def Comedy Jam to the point
that you actually were on def Comedy Jam
two years that's amazing two or three
years and you sit there when you got
there like thinking about that
conversation or was it did not even
occur to you it didn't even occur where
all this is coming back now
ya know did you really call the police
from a house burglarizing a friend of
mine used to breaking houses I was poor
he was poor but he was showing up with
all this nice [ __ ] I'm like dude turn me
on like you got a job he was like yeah I
was like okay and one night he called me
so you ready to go to work oh yeah let's
go so we pulled up in front of this
house I'm like what was this he's like
I'm going to show you you know we broke
in the house and at the time VCRs was
out and we had got all the VCRs
televisions all the [ __ ] that we wanted
we had it all ready at the backdoor
waiting to leave with it
the whole time it was a German Shepherd
in the house and it wasn't doing [ __ ]
was rubbing his head and doing all kind
of [ __ ] and when we was about to leave
his
started getting agitated the dog was
like what I want you he's like every
time we go towards the door he would get
upset so I was like okay so my buddy
said [ __ ] that dog and ran I said what
the [ __ ] you do that for ran behind
we ran upstairs and slammed the door man
I'm scared
upstairs in a bedroom so what a good
plan bedroom we went in had these are
storm windows on them where they
wouldn't come up so we couldn't get out
the window so my boy was like man I'm
about to do something I was like dude
you throw something through the window
we're going to jail anyway
so I said I'm calling police because I'd
rather get I rather go to jail and get
chewed up yeah dispatch thought I was
playing thought I was a kid I was like
no [ __ ] we are trapped by dogs in a
beer room at this address
they sent the cops cops came up there
laughing called us all kind of dummies
and morons like you got to be one of the
stupidest [ __ ] I just said put
your hands behind your back oh god and
then did you end up like getting
arrested for burglary you know and yeah
I went to jail for burger how long did
you do for that I end up doing like six
months I was a juvenile I was in
juvenile I was I did six months and then
they put me on this thing called
suspended commitment I just thought that
you do six months in juvie instead of
getting bit by it by that doggie crazy